hello I'm Margaret drain vice president
of national productions
WGBH and for those of you who do not
know WGBH we're big production house in
Boston and we produce about a third two
of the primetime shows for PBS we do
some commercial producing also but our
basic mission is to produce or PBS and
we have long been active and trying to
exploit all the digital platforms that
we have let me explain some of the shows
that I'm responsible for GBH produces
Nova frontline American experience those
are the three big nonfiction series
additionally reproduced masterpiece
theater mystery and antiques roadshow so
that's the sort of this the stable that
I run each of those shows has its own
digital platforms and has exploited
digital rights in lots of different ways
but what I'm going to talk about today
I'm going to try to stick to the time I
was a commercial television producer so
I know that time is important and
deadlines are important but I've spent
too much time in PBS so my inclination
is to make this a 14 part series rest
assured I will not we have a couple of
projects I wanted to introduce you to
because their new projects and we're
using digital rights in a way we haven't
ever before and they're represent
programs from different genres we shall
remain is a big five part historical
series on the history of Native
Americans that's being produced by
American experience the broadcast age is
around 2009 what we wanted to do is to
not tell the whole swath of Native
American history but to select five good
stories that were illustrative of the
struggle of Native Americans to survive
we also wanted to take advantage of the
new media platforms to do a couple of
things one is to increase the public
participation in public broadcasting and
the second was to help bridge the
digital divide now what do I mean by
that what I mean is that we wanted to
engage young Native
Americans in a way that we had never
been able to before and so we came up
with this thing called it's a citizen
storyteller project and what we set out
as our goal is to recruit 200 young
Native Americans and provide them with
new cell phone technology news new cell
phones that could not only record great
video but also you can edit on it and we
would train them in the technology we
would train them in narrative
storytelling if they chose to do a non
narrative that's fine but they we off we
will offer them editorial help through
these training programs our partner in
this is the heard museum in Phoenix and
what we will do we hope we will get 200
really good little films they'll be
short films probably under three minutes
we're going to post them on the web for
we shall remain we're going to have a
little Online Film Festival the heard
museum is going to make a selection of
the best of to show in their native
american film festival and using this
new cell phone technology will be will
be able to transmit the the film's from
cellphone to cellphone so it's a very
very exciting project we had a little um
pilot that we ran for 10 students
recently two weeks ago so i really don't
have anything to show you but what i did
want to show you for those of you who
haven't seen it is the quality of the
video what you're going to see is just
basically one stupid little shot which
is a pan down of a cactus but you'll see
how beautiful it is and over the weekend
I was in Dallas at the PBS convention
and I got my hands on one of these
little cell phones it was an Okie I
think it cost 750 or eight hundred
dollars had a beautiful little screen
and I made my own little video in my
hotel room which I did not bring to show
you because it would be too embarrassing
but let me just show you the quality
because it's really great this woman was
very interesting
she lives in Pima Salt River tribe she
did not volunteer for this project what
we did is we went out to the reservation
see how clear that is I don't know if
that showing up but on my screen it's
just fabulous she we went out to the
reservation to recruit her and she had
never operated a video camera I've never
operated herself you know done anything
but cell phone didn't have a cell phone
and we brought her into the workshop and
she's turned out to be one of the star
students which is great because it's
it's exposing to her off to a whole new
digital environment our other partners
in this project or the Smithsonian and I
mentioned the heard museum we have all
the humanities councils from a number of
different states and of course the
network of nearly 300 public television
stations that we will be able to draw on
so this is a great little project that
we've got going I think we've finally
finished raising the money for it so
we'll be able to do I hope come close to
the goal of having 200 little videos so
stay tuned the next project comes from
nova which is our ongoing science series
called car of the future it's a one-hour
program answering one question is that
how can today's drivers transition to a
new breed of vehicles that's less
dependent on oil and produces few fewer
greenhouse gases so I wanted to just
show you a little clip of the show and
you'll see you'll get a better sense of
what's in it and then I'll talk I'll
tell you about what's different about
this Nova show from all of all of the
other Nova shows
try to imagine 800 million cars if you
put them bumper to bumper they circle
the Earth 125 times that so many cars
are on the road today they come in all
shapes and colors but have one thing in
common our transportation system is
almost entirely fueled by petroleum more
than ninety five percent a quarter of
all the petroleum ever consumed in the
history of the world was consumed in the
last ten years so we are consuming as an
accelerating rate what is scary is that
projections suggest that by 2050
there'll be 2 billion vehicles two and a
half times as many as there are today
there's an energy shortage looming
somewhere in our future and if we do
nothing it could be a real crisis can I
change the station why no you can't this
is important stuff it's scaring me I
don't like it anymore oh come on up with
such a sissy two brothers have embarked
on a quest to investigate this
transportation dilemma wow I don't know
we're not in Kansas anymore i can tell
you that they want to find out what's
being done right now that will keep our
cars moving in the future stand back
they're putting new technology to the
test they're experimenting with advanced
alternative fuels and they're getting
behind the wheels of vehicles that who
knows maybe come the car of the future
join them on their journey of discovery
right now on Nova
you recognize those guys so it's a very
amusing look at what it was a very
serious problem with click and clack now
what's unusual about this project is
that we have a web component which we
call open production which went up well
in advance of the broadcast and the
producer Joe Siemens put a draft script
their treatment up for people to take a
look at also put up a list of potential
invite interviewees and encourage people
to send in their ideas critic critique
the script add some questions that they
would ask the interviewees suggest names
of other people that he might
incorporate it and so we brought them
into the process of production and he
has taken some of these to heart as he's
gone off to shoot the film so as you can
see you can there's a draft script car
of the future you know about the
producers expert participants so you can
join in this discussion and since the
launch of this website we've had over
900 emails of people submitting their
questions and ideas and the discussion
board has attracted more than 300 posts
and over 10,000 views on topics such as
micro compact cars electric vehicles etc
roughly thirty percent of these emails
have come from educators and I should
put it on put you on pause right now
because Nova is one of the most used
Nova's website is one of the most used
educational sites for science teachers
throughout the country so it's
critically important that we reach this
group of people we also got little did
we know input from people who have their
own versions of the car of the future
these are these are guys who are men and
women who have built their own cars who
have fiddled to have tinkered or
recommending certain cars so you can
click on any one of these and you can
see their own personal view of their
their car of the future so it's good
user-generated content the material that
we're providing for car of the future
will be going to go back the scenic sand
animation will be available for open
content the interviews will be available
for screening and streaming online both
the video and you will be able to access
the transcripts they will not be made
available for open content and I should
emphasize that we at gbh feel very
strongly that we have a bond between our
interviewees and experts whom we solicit
particularly in areas where we do
investigative reporting like frontline
and it's very difficult to persuade the
interviewees to appear on our show and
also give us carte blanche for allowing
their interviews to be mixed in mash so
that is our position the next project is
teachers domain which I'm sort of
coincidentally involved in but teachers
domain actually harkins do something
Rick was talking about this morning
about segmenting of archival material
and what we have with teachers domain is
a library a digital library of
educational resources for K through 12
which is taken from all of the primetime
shows that we produce so more than a
hundred thousand teachers use this
resource we have a thousand what we call
clips or resources on the in the library
right now many of them you can download
and remix but not all of them we did get
a grant from the Hewlett Foundation to
take a look at some of the resources
with the with the goal of trying to
clear as much as possible for open
content we often can't do that because
as suit kantrowitz mentioned this
morning that it's very difficult with
our third party rights holders I just
got a three minute countdown here so I
have to speed it up I guess in teachers
domain what we do have is four different
levels
of usage which we can I can talk about
that if you're interested in getting
more detail about this we are very
excited about the potential for teachers
domain because previously PBS had not
been our relationship with PBS had been
somewhat strained under the new regime
at PBS we found that we are in sync with
them so we expect teachers demain to
become the kind of national network for
public television offered throughout the
country and the statistics are really
incredible but I won't sort of go
through the whole list of things you can
see that this there's a whole thing on
Judah Folkman and his theory about blood
and the contribution to the growth of
cancer right this is a project that is
absolutely brand-new it hasn't even
started and we don't have the funding
yet we should hear next week whether we
have the full funding it's called
adoption families it is a online
broadcast that starts online and
finishes up on television so it's a
complete reversal of the conventional
way of thinking we got to this by
accident because we had initially
conceived of this as a broadcast and we
went we designed a web project that we
thought was going to help us raise money
for production it didn't we learn some
things from it but one of the ideas that
came out of it was to just go online and
do it as a web project and we are
selecting three families and we'll give
them video cameras and they will record
every week they will record their
experiences that week in the adoption
process each of them is in a different
stage in the adoption process we will
also encourage people from around the
country who have gone through adoption
to add their comments or helpful hints
for example if one of the families is
going to be visited by a social worker
one of these families may want to share
what happened to them when before the
social worker came and offer them tips
for a successful visit or things to
watch out for we also have a whole
website that when we started the funding
website it generated all of these what
we call phases of a
option and family spent sent in pictures
and story pictures of their own adopted
children and stories about them which
was very heartfelt moving so we're going
to keep that component of the website up
and running we will assign producers to
each of the three families take the
material that has already been on the
web shoot some additional material and
put it on for a 90-minute broadcast
sometime in 2008 after the broadcast we
will continue to follow the progress of
each of these three families by tracking
them for as long as we can support the
the endeavor even if we have enough
money to follow them for a year it would
be great and keep the website open and
available to everyone so questions later
on but that's what WGBH